foreign
tutorial
now in today's session we will be
talking about certain data sets which we
will use for our SQL programming
now let me introduce you to the two data
sets which we are going to use today in
our session one is employee attrition
now as you can see we are using MySQL as
our SQL database in which we have
already prepared databases for two
tables one is employee attrition and
another is Olympic events
so in this due course of this session we
will be showing you certain queries
certain analytics which you can perform
on different types of
the data columns which are present and
what intelligent inferences you can make
out of this data so we are going to use
first talk about the employee attrition
now let me first make you aware what
kind of columns data types and data
which we have prepared
now if you see the employee attrition
table
there are these columns so I'll just try
to alter the table first
okay so employee attrition table these
are the columns like age attrition
business travel daily rate
Department Etc I'll show you the sample
values okay and employee ID is the
primary key which is and it's Auto
increment
so basically any new data any new
employee details which will be entered
in this table our new ID will get
generated for the
uh employee automatically by the
database
so just to let you know we are using
MySQL workbench which is the tool
available to interact to a query server
now now you can see the table you have
the age of the employee whether it is
the employee has exited attrition yes or
no what was the business travel
frequency what was the daily rate of
particular employee Department to which
he belongs distance home education field
which education background he belongs to
environment satisfaction the work
environment satisfaction this is the
feedback survey data which has been
accumulated the gender of the uh
employee hourly rate
job involvement job level
what is this what was his role his or
our role uh the level of job
satisfaction marital status monthly
income monthly rate number of companies
total the employee has worked whether he
performs over time yes or no the salary
hike which he has been given uh the
performance rating his or her
relationship satisfaction total number
of working years work-like balance total
number of years at the current company
and years in the current role and years
in last year since last promotion so
these are important in order to identify
uh you know whether the employees having
uh you know has received the promotion
this is the uh basis the salary hike
performance rating
Etc so we will look what how what all we
can do with this data and last is
employee ID
okay now basic SQL Curry query View Run
select star employee nutrition and you
get the entire data okay
now for example I want to get a query to
find the details of employees under
attrition employee attrition having five
plus years of experience
so what we will do now is we will do a
select star from employee attrition
table but now we will apply filters like
what is the age of the employees we want
between 27 and 35 so the first filter
which we will apply is that we will get
the list of employees which are in the
bracket of age 27 to 35 so we will use
something called as a between Clause so
between 27 and 35 means 27 and 35
inclusive okay so you can see a person
with age 27 and also you can see a
person with 835
now what else we need is that who are
having five plus years of experience
right so there is a column called
total working years okay so basically we
want anyone which is more than or equal
to 5 okay so we'll say total working
years greater than equal to 5.
now if you see the total working
experience column working years column
any one which is more than equal to 5 is
a present
now you might want to check what is the
total count of this whole you know data
set you can say total select count
star
and run the query again so total 455
employees and what is the total count of
our data set without any filter
one four seven zero so 455 out of one
four seven zero are the employees which
are having five plus years of experience
and belong to age group 27 and 35.
so I'll roll this back
and I'll
find my query again
now this is one example of a very
straightforward filter criteria and we
have used the between clause now let's
take a look at another example
fetch the details of employees having
maximum and minimum salary working in
different departments and who have
received less than 13 salary hike now
less than 13 percent salary hike so
there is a column called percentage
salary hike so we need someone who is
less than 13 so we will put the filter
criteria of less than 13
now secondly we want the maximum and
minimum salary per Department in
different department so first of all
what we have to do is I'll
first break this query for you guys
so first let's just filter
the set of employees who are having
salary hike less than 13 percent
okay
everyone who has less than 13 percent is
now in my list
now now we need to use our another
feature of SQL analytics is called Group
by now we want what is the maximum and
minimum salary in each department which
people with less than 13 salary hike
have received so first of all you need
to use a class called as Group by
department now Group by Department means
that we are gonna get all the data
grouped by Department it is just like in
Excel when you create a pivot the and in
the pivot when you drag and drop a
column in the rows section so basically
in the pivot you're trying to group by
that particular column similarly in SQL
this is a very synonymous to pivoting
you're pivoting the data by department
now when you are pivoting basically in a
group grouping by here you have to use a
analytical function like Max Min sum
average count
Etc so here now our question is maximum
and minimum salary so first what I'll do
is I'll say what's my maximum monthly
income
for example and per Department let's
just take first example per Department
okay so in the sales people who have
received less than 13 salary hike their
maximum monthly income is
9924
and research and development
9980. you want you can order by
Max monthly income descending so the
highest one will come at the top okay so
research and development has the maximum
monthly income
uh sales the next and Human Resources
next now I also want minimum monthly
income
so here you go you will get both the
parameters but we are sorting only by
the max so in research and development
okay the people who have uh less than uh
salary hike of 13 percent have maximum
monthly income of 9980 and minimum of 10
000.
okay
now for example you want to
first do a group by and then perform a
filter then you need to use a clause
having and then
like this
okay so this is an example which showed
you how you use Group by and having
now let's take another example
calculate the average monthly income of
all employees who worked more than three
years and whose education background is
Medical
okay so now
similarly what we have to do is
first
let's first get the details of the
employees who are who have spent more
than three years at this company and are
from education field medical
now these are this this is the list of
the all the employees okay who have
who belong to this filter criteria but
now I want the average monthly income
across all these employees who fit into
this filter criteria so I'll do by Group
by education field and anyways it's only
medical so I have to use a function
mathematical function average AVG
monthly income and I will get the
average monthly income which is 7345 so
basically people employees who have
spent more than three years in the
company and belong to the medical
education field have an average monthly
income of 7345.
you want to do group by or not it
doesn't matter because anyways it's a
filter criteria so you can discard this
group by
okay
now next identify the total number of
male and female employees under
attrition whose marital status is
married and haven't received promotion
in last two years okay so now our
criteria is
select first let me just say select star
from employee attrition whose marital
status is equal to Merit and year since
last promotion is
2.
okay so who haven't received promotion
since last promotions in last two years
equal to two now this is my data set now
after the filter criteria
and
attrition equal to yes
okay now these are the employees now I
want the total number of male and female
employees so now
I have to apply Group by because I now
want
a group by gender
a group by gender and the count of male
and female employees who belong who fit
into this criteria
so eight male and two females are
is the total count of the employees who
belong to this criteria
where their marital status is married
years since last promotion is only two
and attrition is yes
okay so now you should be able to
understand where when to use Group by
and when not Group by is required when
you need to do a pivoting or you know a
group by basis a particular textual
column and then you need a relevant
calculated measure or number associated
with it using a mathematical function
like count sum average
Etc
next employees with Max performance
rating but no promotion for four years
and above okay now this is an
interesting thing now let's first of all
find in our data set what is the maximum
performance rating which has been given
to a particular employee first let's
check our data set
let's take a glance at the data set
performance rating okay so people have
performance trading as three
four five Etc three or four I believe so
let's see what is the maximum
performance rating so maximum
performance rating is four okay so no
one has received greater than four so I
need uh the list of employees with
maximum performance rating as four uh
sorry at maximum performance rating but
no promotion for four years and above
okay so first of all what I'll do is
I'll
write a sub query where I'll check like
this above select Max performance rating
from employee attrition and then I'll in
the where Clause of performance rating
should be equal to this right so if
tomorrow in my data set there is a
employee who is received a performance
rating of 5 so then this query will
automatically start returning five okay
then what is the ER since last promotion
is greater than equal to 4 and then now
I can run this query
okay so now you can see uh this is the
list of employees who have received
maximum performance rating but haven't
received promotion is uh more than four
years greater than equal to four years
okay
now next
who has maximum and minimum percentage
of salary hike
okay so now I want to check
who which particular set of employees
who have received spent x amount of
years at company
have a good perform have a performance
rating and year since last promotion but
what is their maximum and minimum
percentage salary hike
so for example what I wanted to show
with this data set is that people with
one year at company performance rating
has four years since last promotion is
zero uh means they are very recently you
know been promoted uh but uh their
salary hike maximum salary hike which
they got which those set of employees
have received is 25 and minimum is 20 uh
right and years at company similarly so
this data set is actually sorted by uh
descending order of Maximum percentage
of salary hike and then ascending order
of minimum percentage of salary height
so anyone who has all these set of
employees who have maximum of 25 but
minimum of 22
25 right so the the criteria the query
which we have used is we have grouped by
years at company performance rating
years since last promotion and within
that we have found out what is the max
and minimum percentage of salary hike
now after grouping it we have
reused order by clause in the order by
first we are descending means highest
first lowest uh later of Maximum
percentage salary high and then after
you have the Sorting of Maximum minimum
percentage salary hike should be in
ascending lowest first and higher later
okay
now another very important uh keyword
within SQL is distinct so for example I
want to find out what are the set of
distinct uh departments in my uh
uh you know in my office or in my
organization so these are the set of
departments to which anyone any employee
belongs to so you can use distinct
now next take another example
employees working overtime but get given
minimum salary hike and are more than
five years with company okay now I want
to check that there are people who are
working overtime but they are given
minimum salary hike and already are more
than five years with the company right
so similarly first I'll try to find out
what is the minimum percentage of salary
hike uh given in The Firm
oh sorry
which is 11 okay so now first I'll get
this list of employees who have spent
over time who have done over time and
receive minimum uh percentage salary
height and are also spend more than five
years in the company
so this is a pretty small data set and
if and even if I apply and attrition
equal to s
okay so you can see uh
one two three four five six seven eight
nine people have left the firm because
of probably uh they spent they were
spending over time they were given
minimum salary hike and they were
already with the firm for the last five
years so this is a good uh finding which
can be presented to the management that
you know these are the probably the
reason why people are leaving
now similarly uh you can also check just
by flipping the uh conditions okay
people are who are the people who are
doing over time and have received
maximum salary hike now so now if I want
to check what is the maximum salary hike
which has been given in The Firm is 25
so people have received 25 salary hike
but I have only spent less than five
years in The Firm okay so okay great I
only get one person who belongs to this
criteria so it's a good catch okay you
can check there is a there is a one
person there is an outlier there's an
exceptional case and probably it could
be that the person have performed
extraordinarily or uh what what is the
other reason behind so you can the HR or
any management person can take a look
into it
okay and similarly uh who has not spent
over time people who have not done over
time but have received maximum salary
hike okay again this is also a good
catch you can check they have not done
over time they were not doing over time
but they received maximum salary right
and have spent less than five years in
The Firm so that's also a good thing to
look at that why are these people given
a hike
another one what is a maximum
relationship satisfaction minimum for
people with basis the marital status so
this is a pretty straightforward four
and one so all different kind of
analytics and uh you know uh you can
perform queries you can write queries
you can check you can do make some
inferences derive some inferences
intelligence out of your data you can
mine information you can write queries
so it's a very powerful tool now let's
take a look at our second data set which
is Olympic events
now in this data set
we have columns like ID name of the
Olympian sex age height weight the team
which he or she belongs to uh the code
of the country the games the year in
which the Olympics were done season it
was a summer olympics or Winter Olympics
the city where the events were done the
sport and the name of the event and
whether the player or the participant
won a gold silver bronze or whether he
did not win any medal like any not
applicable now so basically it's an
interesting data set let's see what all
inferences what all queries we can kind
of fire in this and make some
intelligence intelligent inference out
of it okay so this is the basic query
select star uh from your schema name dot
the table name
now first query which I want to find out
is write an SQL query to find in which
port or event India has won the highest
medals it could be gold silver bronze
but not any okay so I want to get a
count of the total medals daily of India
according to each event in which it has
participated and I want the highest to
lowest medal tally okay so now I'll just
first break up this query for you
so let's first say select star from
Olympic events where team is equal to
India
now this is the entire data set filter
data where India has participated and
these are the participants now I am
excluding which is not equal to
I am excluding all this all those events
where India has not won a medal so okay
so now excluded those events so now
India has medals with bronze gold and
silver now I want account of all these
medals per event now it makes sense for
me to do a group by
event so now I am doing a group by now
in my select Clause I can have event
or any other aggregation or number
crunching which I want to do now my goal
is to get the medals tally so Group by
event and get the count of The Middle so
India has won 28 medals in men's hockey
one in shooting rifle and one in
wrestling men's wrestling okay so total
30 13 is the total count and out of that
this is the breakup
okay by default you can see the data is
already sorted but you can also put a
sorting Clause order by count of middle
descending and you will get the same
result 28 1 1. such a good inference you
can check uh even if you want that in
which year
per year wise breakup if you want
so you can use this column here
and say for example you just say ear and
event
now let's see what we get
okay so now in this in 1932 men's hockey
we got the maximum medals then 1952 then
1928 either you can sort so we have
sorted by descending highest middle
count to the lowest middle count or if
you want to order by year
so here you have the latest one from
2012 to 1928 which is now the data is
sorted by ear descending or you can say
voltage to low earliest which is 28 to
2012. so all the options are available
so but we want to see what is a problem
statement which you want to solve
next last example
identify the sports or even which was
placed most
consecutively in the Summer Olympic
Games okay so now
similarly now we want only the Summer
Olympics so what we will do is
Olympic events where season equal to
Summer
okay now I have filtered that data and
event
Group by event
and get the count of that particular
event
now I want to sort it my football men's
football is the most uh played
event okay so again say order by event
count scripting descending
okay so football men's football 1545
events hockey uh base basketball water
polo cycling rowing Athletics men 400
meter uh relay 100 meters so this is the
descending order of the events
next example
write an SQL query to fetch the details
of all the countries which have won most
number of silver and bronze medals and
at least one gold medal now this is
interesting we want a count of separate
count of medals tally which is silver
bronze and gold separately first okay so
now we will take an example of a case
statement now in SQL what I have to do
first is I have to query the Olympic
events table and I have to check in
which case I have the uh the team or the
player I want silver I'll say if someone
has won silver give say then one l0 if
someone has bronze one bronze then one
l0 someone has won Gold one l0 so I have
basically created three columns separate
columns basis the condition of whether
the person is winning silver bronze and
gold now I'm just gonna run this query
independently
and if you see in the end now I have
three new columns introduced z uh basis
the count of the gold silver and bronze
so suppose for this example uh this
player has won Gold so he has one in
front of the gold okay someone has grown
bronze so there's a one here now I'll
use these three columns to do a sum to
get the total tally of silver bronze and
gold separately
so now if You observe I have prepared a
put this in a in a query and on top of
this query now I am writing another
query which is select team comma sum of
silver column sum of groans sum of gold
and I am grouping by team so now
if you see this
China has won 32 Silver 27 drones 41
gold Denmark Etc now I have
per team
it's medals tally silver bronze gold but
now I have to put a condition that I
only want a list of teams which have at
least won one gold means the sum of gold
tally should be greater than zero so now
I will use my having close so after
doing my group pin I am applying the
having Clause it means I should remove
all the teams which does not which have
gold equal to zero okay so now if I
apply this
there is no team now left in my data set
which is having
zero goals at least one gold is there
okay now idea is to solve which has won
the most number of silver and bronze
medal now I have to do sort by silver
let's do that
okay so now if you see United States
have won most number of silver and
bronze medals but at least have one gold
so this is the actual output which is
what we want okay
next is France Italy and if you go to
the bottom the last there is
uh if you see Scotia or
China 2 or any other example
uh I'll just take another example
Uzbekistan
Ireland Indonesia if you see only one
gold and one silver so that's why it's
at the bottom of the table Uzbekistan
for gold but at least they have one gold
okay
next
another very obvious thing which you
might come to mind which player has won
the maximum number of gold okay so
similar to the previous query we will
again create a column with a case
statement that give me a count of
uh only gold and then
on top of it I'll use the name of the
player
Group by name rather than the team and
find
and then sort by sum of gold
see Matthew Nicholas has won eight goals
Ole Aina 8 Hussein bold eight goals okay
then Nikolai seven Victor all these so
this is the
sorted order of your
gold Style
next which sport has maximum events very
simple Group by Sport and get a count
star
and then sort
Athletics is the maximum events which
have happened
gymnastics swimming
and again similar question which year
has shown the maximum number of events
which year wherever Max 1992 there were
maximum events in 1988 then 2016 then
2000
so you can see you know 1992 was the
maximum number of events which were
played so these are the kind of
you know intelligent inferences SQL
mining you can do on
on this data set
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here